[Music]
you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up
another delay for the government's
energy strategy amid reports of a
cabinet split over the cost of nuclear
power
the future for consumers looks difficult
with energy bills set to rise to their
highest level in more than 60 years
and a breakthrough moment for the
airline industry british airways
announces it's using sustainable jet
fuel produced at scale in the uk
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world hear from
the people being hit hardest by those
changes and report on the race for
solutions
now the war in ukraine has changed
everything the effects of that conflict
are playing out in ways which no one
could have predicted before the invasion
with much of the west now trying to
reduce its dependency on russian oil and
gas many countries including the uk are
grappling with how to secure long-term
supplies of energy and while we await a
government strategy for energy supplies
there's a renewed focus on nuclear power
with the proportion of nuclear in our
electricity mix slowly declining the
prime minister says he wants a quarter
of all our electricity to be from
nuclear in future our science and
technology editor tom clark reports from
north wales
in their day the two reactors at trous
venus made enough power for a city the
size of manchester
this plant shut down 30 years ago but
some of its core components will be
radioactive for centuries
the remaining waste is being boxed up
for long-term storage what you can see
here is concrete boxes
inside which there's another box and
inside that
there's what's called intermediate level
waste so this is what you see
as waste that's come from
half a century of nuclear generation for
a long time the assumption was the site
to be effectively forgotten but the
energy crisis means they're being eyed
as the best places for a nuclear
renaissance
our job as magnox is to decommission the
site and do that in a safe and
sustainable way to enable this site to
be reused and regenerated for whatever
use we all decide is needed here
at a peak in 1997 15 power plants
produced more than a quarter of the uk's
electricity but by 2024 only three will
still be generating and by 2030 there
will be just two size well b and the
long delayed hinckley c in somerset
last week at a number 10 round table the
prime minister said he wanted 25 of our
energy to come from nuclear once again
executives from rolls-royce were there
trying to persuade him of a new approach
small modular reactors we've designed
this solution in order to ensure we've
got a much more robust route to market
with a technology that can be financed
with private capital and that is by
design
a product that is lower cost and can be
built in a factory best case scenario
worst case scenario when do you think
we'll see well hopefully if you come and
speak to me in a year's time we'll be in
the middle of those negotiations
rolls-royce's reactor is based on its
designs used in nuclear submarines to
make smrs faster and less complex to
build they'll be pre-fabricated in
modules
so this is a an example of a module
right so the sm1 component yes
one module this is modular constructed
so it's
built in a factory environment taken to
site and then modules assembled together
so you're taking all that risk out of
the construction
while investment risks may be lower smrs
still need to be proven in the real
world
they'll face stiff competition from
rival bids for bigger nuclear plants and
neither is a quick fix for the energy
crisis or the challenge of net zero
it's right perhaps that the government
has nuclear as part of
of its strategy i certainly expect that
it would do that but it's quite wrong to
think that we can we can get nuclear in
time new nuclear in time the next winter
winter after that or in fact for many
years
to some sites like this are the legacy
of an expensive and messy chapter in our
energy history to others they're
monuments to an era of high-tech
home-grown zero-carbon electricity
reminding us how short-term thinking can
end up costing us more in the long run
tom clark sky news north wales
well the government was due to announce
its long-awaited energy supply strategy
this week that however has been delayed
again so let's bring in tom clark who we
just heard from and tom you were telling
us there about the possible role of
nuclear power in in the future but what
about the rest of the strategy and why
haven't we heard yet from the government
it's a remarkable delay uh and this is
something given the urgency of the
energy crisis that yeah we were hoping
to get quite speedily and i think the
prime minister wants to get it through
the understanding is there's there's a
split over nuclear the cost of nuclear
power has been a big deterrent to people
in the treasury
and you can see why the only nuclear
power station we're building at the
moment hinckley c has gone massively
over budget 23 billion pounds it's
projected to cost that's making it
possibly the most expensive energy
project ever put on the face of the
earth you see why they don't want to
repeat that yet nuclear industry as you
saw in my report there lobbying the
prime minister we can do things better
we can do them cheaper we can reduce
those risks but the costs are high
and nuclear isn't going to deliver
um
immediate reductions in our dependency
on fossil fuels which is what that
strategy needs to do
but in the absence of
lots of short-term options uh it's
certainly something the government needs
to consider
as well as our commitments to net zero
of course and nuclear power is a source
of net zero electricity
too
now if you put those things into the mix
and the extreme expense they cost the
fossil fuel price rises at the moment
actually makes nuclear look reasonably
affordable and it's sort of a lack of
long-term thinking you could argue put
us in this situation in the first place
the thing that you know some people
prefer is maybe we continue building gas
as energy security priority but we to
mitigate the fossil fuel risk we use
carbon capture and storage to bury the
carbon dioxide but interestingly the
treasury axed the one billion pot of
money back in 2015 for that so a lesson
there about this long-term thinking when
it comes to any energy security which
you've maybe missed in the past that's
certainly what the nuclear industry will
be trying to persuade the government of
at the moment
tom thanks very much indeed and we'll
actually be discussing all of this
energy security and more broadly how the
war in ukraine has affected our net zero
strategy with the founder and director
of terror praxis kirsty gogan and
professor of political economy at the
university of sheffield michael jacobs
that's a little later
but now let's take a look at some
today's other climate news and british
airways has become the first airline to
use sustainable aviation fuel produced
on a commercial scale in the uk
sustainable aviation fuel production
reduces carbon emissions by around 80
percent compared with traditional jet
fuel but is currently more expensive
british airways parent group iag has a
target of powering 10 of all flights
with sustainable fuel by 2030
uk farmers could soon be paying hundreds
of millions of pounds more a year for
fertilizer as russia's invasion of
ukraine continues to hit supply chains
in 2020 the uk imported more than 22 000
tonnes of fertilizer from russia one of
the world's largest producers the energy
and climate intelligence unit says a
handful of british companies are leading
the way in developing net zero
fertilizers and that could help to start
cut
britain's dependence on russia
national grid has sold a 60 stake in its
gas network to a group of global
investors in a move it says will make
the network ready for the transition to
net zero by 2050. the deal with the
consortium is reported to be worth 2.2
billion pounds and national grid says it
will help the business pivot towards
electricity
now the energy price cap is set to rise
at the end of this week with the war in
ukraine making an already difficult
energy supply situation even more
complicated it's inevitable that prices
will rise again in the autumn so let's
take a look at our data dashboard and we
can see how much we rely on gas i mean
today in particular
there's a low output from renewables so
well over half of our electricity is
coming from gas 57 percent there our
economics editor ed conway has been
taking a look at what we can expect
the bank of england governor says we
could be facing a historic squeeze on
our incomes as a result of the energy
crisis
the shock from energy prices this year
will be larger than any single year in
the 1970s
so larger than any single year in the
1970s actually that could be a bit of an
understatement and i'll show you why in
a second but first of all let's have a
look at those energy prices so this is
gas prices wholesale gas prices that
your supplier is potentially paying
going back to the last year now you'll
remember in december we thought that
level that it hit there that peak there
uh was high well it was high it was
unprecedented but look at what happened
after the invasion of ukraine it went up
to crazy levels really incredibly high
levels it has come down a bit since then
so down a bit still high but but down a
bit why is that it's partly because
contrary to what you might have thought
actually there is quite a lot of russian
gas still flowing uh to the eu in fact
more
than before the invasion just look at
that line it's higher than before the
invasion the highest level that we've
seen so far this year so there's a lot
going on here but it's worth just
picking apart what that means for our
bills and how much of our income we pay
on them and i can show you this line
goes all the way back to the 1950s the
blue area there is the kind of range the
share of our expenditure that's going on
our energy and you can see it's actually
been relatively low in recent decades
but look at what happens uh at the end
of this week uh the start of april when
that price cap uh comes in so that's
just under two thousand pounds highest
level uh since the mid-1980s as a result
of that um but the question now is what
happens
next and in october the obr the office
special responsibility they said last
week they did the official forecast for
the government they said potentially a
price cap of 2 800 pounds and just to
put that into perspective look at that
red line that is higher so the share of
what we're paying at the share of our
expenditure that's going on it the
higher than we've ever seen before the
70s but also the 60s also a lot of the
50s as well now bear in mind you've got
to factor in the fact that you've got
that 350 pounds in a council tax cut
rebates that are coming through from the
government so you bear that in mind but
even after you do that look that red
line still above those levels that we
peaks that we've seen going back to
1950s however as i showed you a moment
ago those prices are yoyoing around
quite a lot at the moment so
every single day that calculation
changes right now it's not looking like
2800 pounds it's looking more like this
is the latest forecast more like
2490 pounds so lower but still the red
line above anything we've paid uh before
as a share of our incomes but here again
you've got to do that calculation so
bear in mind what the government's doing
350 pounds take that off and we're down
to well it's not the highest level since
the mid 80s it's the highest level since
the early 80s even so we're talking
about historic uh thing going on here
maybe even tougher than what the bank of
england governor was talking about
now businesses wanting to sell bugs as
food in the uk have warned they're in
limbo because of the lack of a
post-brexit agreement for the sector
insects are a sustainable low-carbon
source of protein and have been promoted
as a future solution to
food scarcity and the climate crisis a
trade body representing edible insect
businesses hopes that a decision from
the food standards agency will give them
blanket approval to trade from june
do stay with us coming up i'll be joined
by founder and director of terra praxis
kirsty gogan and michael jacobs
professor of political economy from the
university of sheffield and we're going
to be discussing what the war in ukraine
means for the race to net zero and if
the nuclear power could be the answer to
the energy crisis
the wind was like pulling us out of that
little room
mandatory evacuation you must leave
i'm greg milam sky's u.s correspondent
here in los angeles
as it is almost impossible to predict
where these fires will go next
[Music]
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
this gives you an idea of the strength
of those wins strong enough to bend and
twist metal
are you trying to run me over to fill it
no go away look like it sir
will you respond to those who made
accusations so philip can you go away
i've seen the dark side of america
we are standing on the supply line right
into the heart of america's opioid
crisis
[Music]
i've seen heartbreaking human stories
there was a river of blood coming out of
the mosque that's a scene that you don't
forget
christchurch has been changed forever by
what happened
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news now we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
founder and director of terror praxis
kirsty gogan and professor of political
economy at the university of sheffield
michael jacobs so a very good evening to
both of you nice to see you both
so russia's invasion of ukraine has
changed everything for the people of
ukraine of course
for russians where economic sanctions
are beginning to bite and for europe and
western allies who are working out how
to deal with vladimir putin and the
question i'd like to ask is where does
this leave international climate
strategy and the race to net zero
so michael jacobs has the war in ukraine
affected our chances of meeting net zero
do you think as the uk and its
neighbours as well of course
learns to wean itself off russian oil
and gas
well i think that very much depends upon
the nature of the
commitments that governments make
they are trying now to get themselves
off russian oil and gas as you say and
initially that won't have much of a uh
that won't make much of an impact on
climate change targets they're going to
try and get oil and gas from other
countries
but the longer term transition i think
has been or at least could be speeded up
we know that the best way of getting
ourselves off gas and oil in general is
to shift to renewable energy and to stop
wasting energy what we often call energy
efficiency and those things could be
accelerated many people and i would be
one of them would argue that our energy
security and our climate security are
essentially the same thing and i would
now add our national security if we
consider uh the dangers that uh putin
led russia holds for the west so i do
think it's possible that we could see
the impact of ukraine long term as an
acceleration of the shift towards net
zero but it still does depend on the
decisions which governments make
including our own well yes and we will
hear more about that strategy in the
days ahead but kirsty in the meantime
michael they're relatively optimistic
about what the future could hold in
terms of net zero but some people will
say isn't it inevitable that the
government's going to say let's increase
domestic north sea oil and gas
production at least in the short term to
replace
the russian oil and gas that we're we're
weaning ourselves off
yeah that is a big risk and it's you
know even a big risk that we might you
know decide to delay the closure of our
coal plants even you know in light of
this crisis but
i think actually more broadly um you
know this these terrible recent events
have prompted a major rethink in terms
of our you know over dependence really
the folly of over dependence on imported
gas both in terms of you know price
stability as well as energy security and
you know i think governments across
europe are actually beginning now to
look again at nuclear energy alongside
renewables and energy efficiency because
actually all of the evidence tells us
that although nuclear plants appear to
be quite slow
to be built once they are built they are
very very large so in terms of the
overall contribution that they make
towards adding
very reliable very stably priced and
very clean electricity generation to our
grids they're in fact the fastest way to
decarbonize our electric electricity
grids this has been demonstrated
previously in many countries including
sweden and france and i want to pick up
with nuclear again in a moment but first
just a quick thought again on domestic
oil and gas and michael jacobs i mean
the people who say do that now it's
going to be quicker and easier to do it
now to increase north sea oil production
we've got our own domestic supply that
way it's a short-term fix it's got kind
of gives us this base load of secure um
energy
into the mix where renewables have more
vagaries
well we can discuss uh the intermittency
question and the role of nuclear in a
second but in terms of north sea oil and
gas we need to be very careful about
saying that it's a short-term fix it
takes on average 28 years to move from
uh the beginning the exploration process
for new oil gas field and actually oil
and gas coming on stream now that's an
average but of course if it took 28
years that would take us to 2050 and
2050 is the year that we're meant to be
net zero so it's not a short-term
solution even if a new oil and gas field
could come on stream in 15 years but
this is still a very long time
and what we have is an immediate
requirement to move away from russian
oligarchs so it's not a short-term
fix that at all and of course it may
well be that because we are on a
generally declining trend of gas and oil
towards our net zero targets that the
private sector decides that it doesn't
want to invest in new fields because it
won't be able to sell all the oil and
gas
that will be found in them and they will
be left as so-called stranded assets
so i don't think new oil and gas fields
in the north sea is an answer to the
current uh questions that we face and
let's pick up on what kirsty was saying
that nuclear is the answer do you think
that's right i mean i know kirsten
you're i think advising the government
on this subject so you're you're a big
fan of it michael is nuclear that the
way forward
well the advantage of nuclear is that
its base load capacity um when the wind
uh doesn't blow so much and the sun
doesn't shine we need electricity that
is on all the time and
gas and coal-fired power stations have
done that for us in the past along with
nuclear and nuclear could do it in a low
carbon form in the future
the problem is the length of time it
takes to build new nuclear power
stations now
your report from tom earlier talked
about modular nuclear reactors which is
the new kind which are untested yet and
we don't know how long they could come
on stream but we do know that the
traditional large nuclear reactors take
a very long time to come on stream
hinckley point c
um is due to come on stream in 2026
having first been granted planning
permission in 2012. okay i'm going to
pick up a very long time to wait before
we will get that new capacity and in the
meantime new storage technologies for
electricity might well have proved
themselves a better option kirsten let's
pick up on those points then it just
takes way too long we haven't got time
have we with these net zero goals
looming
the thing is is that you know it it is
quite quick to build a solar project for
example but the solar project is a
thousand times smaller uh than a nuclear
plant and
then only has a ten percent capacity
factor which means it generates only ten
percent of its its name plate capacity
so that's why even though these big
nuclear plants do take a long time to
come on board once they're up and
running then they do represent a massive
quantity of electricity that we need but
i think i'd like to broaden this out a
little bit and remember that we're
actually you know only talking about 20
of our energy consumption right now
which is electricity actually what we we
also need to remember is that we have to
decarbonize the other 80
of our energy use which means liquid
fuels which means industry which means
heavy transport shipping aviation those
are really tough to decarbonize sectors
and one of the really big advantages for
nuclear technologies that i'm really
interested in is the fact that they can
produce high temperature heat now that's
something that wind and solar can't do
but it means that they can produce
very um of cost-effective hydrogen-based
clean synthetic fuels and heat for
industrial applications yeah and and
kirsty just one more thing on that very
high heat it's one of the reasons people
get nervous about it look at the
situation in ukraine people have
concerns about the chernobyl nuclear
plant for example people worry about
safety don't they and they worry about
nuclear waste as well so just touch on
those issues if you can
yeah i think we have to look at you know
any of these kind of risks and uh in
context and you know right now the
reality is is that we see seven million
premature deaths per year around the
world every single year from air
pollution so actually focusing on net
zero and cleaning up all of our you know
global fossil fuel-based energy
infrastructure is a really incredible
opportunity not only to you know address
the climate challenges that we face but
also the public health challenges that
we face and when you look at those risks
and those you know real material effects
that we're already experiencing today
before even the climate risks you start
to see that the risks presented by
nuclear energy are very well managed
okay and represent a much smaller risk
to public health in the environment and
finally very quickly just to put to both
of you
michael there's so many different
aspects to this whole issue but is there
a way of getting prices down for
consumers and it being good for the
planet
the best way of getting prices down for
consumers or getting bills down is to
invest in energy efficiency we waste so
much of our energy through our leaky
buildings
and our poor
energy efficiency and insulation
standards and that's not only the
cheapest method
of meeting our energy needs but is also
the thing that will most bring bills
down for
householders so i really want to see
that as the centerpiece of the
government's energy strategy whenever it
comes kirsty quick thought from you on
the same subject
yeah i absolutely agree energy
efficiency is critical we have to do all
of these things at once we have to move
forward in all fronts 28 years to
achieve net zero across our entire
fossil fuel energy system so we need a
very ambitious energy strategy from the
government which does include you know
investments in nuclear energy to deliver
you know cost-effective and very stable
and ultimately very secure reliable
energy
well when we do get that strategy it'd
be really interesting to get your
thoughts on there but for the moment uh
thanks very much indeed both of you for
joining us kester gogan michael jacobs
we appreciate your time thank you
well that's it from us for today but
joining me on the show tomorrow our
chief executive at forum for the future
dr sally uran and executive director of
climate outreach jamie clark thanks for
watching i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you